so basically elon musk he's he's he's
not pulled any punches lately on twitter
he's almost become like the donald trump
of twitter except without being you know
quite mean quite as mean as donald trump
but he basically said today i hereby
challenge vladimir putin to single
combat and the stakes are ukraine he
would get his ass kicked immediately he
probably would i went through the
timeline a little bit and somebody said
something to him like are you serious
bro i don't think you can do that same
thing you're saying putin right right
he's like i am 100 serious
i enjoy though that he's on there
i think it's fun yeah and he followed it
up by the way just because he wasn't
getting the kind of response that he
wanted look when you challenge somebody
to a fight and they ignore you you have
to take it one step further or you walk
away right he took one step further and
he actually tagged the official kremlin
account and said do you agree to this
battle
he's serious russia
what you got